bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte au
début du xxème siècle une découverte
celle de la synthèse de la zot allait
révolutionner l'agriculture
jusque là on dépend des des fumiers pour
fertiliser les champs l'arrivée des
engrais azotés
c'est un des piliers qui a permis au
rendement de faire des bonds fulgurant
mais aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
ces gars là ont un coût pour les
agriculteurs évidemment qui doivent
acheter des engrais mais aussi pour
l'environnement
alors imaginez si le maïs la plante la
plus cultivée dans le monde pouvait se
passer d'azoté ce serait une nouvelle
révolution sur laquelle travaille déjà
des scientifiques
cette plante est une véritable formule 1
elle pousse en ce moment même à une
vitesse folle
peu de plantes sont aussi efficaces que
le maïs pour convertir l'énergie du
soleil
mais il ya une condition
pour soutenir une telle performance le
maïs a besoin de beaucoup d'engrais
détente d'engrais chimiques dont la zot
l'azoté pourtant un fertilisant naturel
qui se retrouvent dans l'air et si
seulement le maïs pouvait tirer son
exode de l'air comme le font certaines
plantes
[Musique]
voici l'histoire d'une formidable
découverte scientifique
elle met en scène un chercheur et un
maïs géant issus des régions
montagneuses du mexique
[Musique]
cette découverte pourrait révolutionner
la culture du maïs la plante la plus
cultivée au monde
université du wisconsin à madison cette
université publique est un des temples
de la recherche agricole aux états unis
ce français a choisi cette institution
réputée pour ses recherches
jean-michel année est une sommité dans
son domaine
il consacre sa vie à étudier un type
particulier de micro-organismes les
bactéries fixatrices d'azoté
ces bactéries qui s'associe avec
certaines plantes
extrait la zot directement de l'air
elles sont l'objet de vieux fantasme
depuis très longtemps la communauté et
les agriculteurs sont conscients qu'il
faut beaucoup d'azoté pour faire pousser
du maïs en particulier et et que cela
pose un problème et il faut cet azote
peut venir d engrais mais beaucoup de
chercheurs sont intéressés par l'idée de
pouvoir avoir cet azote depuis l'ère de
récupérer cet azote d'un de l'air
l'azoté est essentiel aux végétaux et
l'air qu'on respire en contient près de
80% mais les plantes sont incapables
d'assimiler cette forme d'azoté seuls
les légumineuses comme le soya ont cette
capacité
pour y parvenir le soya doit cependant
s'associer aux bactéries fixatrices
d'azoté
ces bactéries vont élire domicile dans
le petit renflement que leur offre le
soya dans ces nodules les bactéries vont
capter puis digérer l'azoté
atmosphérique contenue dans le sol
elles vont ensuite le distribuer au soya
sous une forme facilement assimilable
par la plante en retour le soya fournira
aux bactéries les sucres dont elles ont
besoin pour survivre si de telles
bactéries pouvaient coloniser les
céréales comme le maïs cela réduirait le
recours aux engrais chimiques permettant
ainsi d'économiser des millions de
dollars il ya des articles de chercheurs
du début du xxème siècle qui ai déjà
parlé de cette quête qui disait que
c'était un saint graal qu'il fallait
qu'il fallait poursuivre jean-michel
année poursuit cette quête
[Musique]
voici son terrain d'étude
il renferme des spécimens rares de maïs
regardez bien c'est drôle de structure
ce sont des racines aériennes elles sont
énormes
elle sécrète un gène mystérieux ce maïs
pousse normalement à 4000 km plus au sud
mexique lieu d'origine et de
domestication du maïs la diversité de
cette plante est stupéfiante
des villages entiers cultive encore des
centaines de variétés de maïs il y a dix
ans dans le paysage montagneux de l'état
du oaxaca au mexique
deux chercheurs de l'université davis en
californie font une découverte étonnante
alan bennett et howard shapiro tombe sur
maïs géant
il fait plus de 5 mètres de haut ce qui
surprend les chercheurs c'est que ce
maïs pousse sur un sol pauvre
comment peut-il atteindre une telle
hauteur dans un tel sol où dit il ces
nutriments dont la zot
les chercheurs ont alors une étui sion
ses racines surdéveloppé pourrait-elle
extraire la zone de l'air un peu comme
le font les nodules des légumineuses
il se tourne alors vers le spécialiste
de la question ou aux états unis
ma première réaction c'était noro c'est
impossible c'est très courant que j'ai
en fait des gens qui ne me voir en me
disant qu'ils pensent qu'un magnifique
16 autres et donc c'est vrai que quand
alan bennett et howard shapiro mon monde
ils m'ont demandé si je pensais que
c'était possible je redis certainement
pas
le chercheur se laissera malgré tout
séduire par ce maïs il va y consacrer
cinq années de sa vie
jean-michel anin fouilles d'abord ce gel
mystérieux
[Musique]
il découvre qu'il est colonisé par des
milliards de bactéries et peuvent elles
captent et l'azoté atmosphérique son
équipe s'attelle à cette tâche et mesure
la consommation de la zot par ces
bactéries
les premiers résultats montrent que ces
bactéries utilise bel et bien là zot de
l'air et le chercheur n'y crois pas
quand on a vu les premiers résultats je
me souviens d'une réunion à l'université
de californie davis avec howard et alan
et je leur ai dit que il fallait
chercher quelle est l art et fact quel
était le problème d'où venait cette cet
artefact parce que ça me paraissait
notamment possible
il change alors de méthodes d' analyse
mais encore une fois les mêmes résultats
positifs
rien à faire il refuse toujours d'y
croire parce que justement il ya eu trop
de déception parce que ça fait cent ans
qu'on cherche des choses comme ça que ça
fait cent ans que personne n'a rien
trouvé efficace
saison après saison son équipe continue
de cultiver le maïs mexicain
le chercheur ajoute une troisième
méthode d'analysé
il obtient alors une consommation d'azov
équivalente à la luzerne une autres
légumineuses
il se met alors à croire à ces résultats
oh
quand j'ai réalisé que je ne suis qu'une
une seule des racines aériennes de ce
maïs avait avait des bactéries avec une
activité de nitrogène has au niveau
d'une plante de luzerne avec toute son
autorité tout series opium
là on s'est dit là il ya quelque chose
il faudra deux autres années pour
confirmer ce qui était devenu
incontestable le maïs doux oaxaca se
nouent les belles et biais de la zot
contenue dans l'air on était vraiment
voici on était vraiment fou deux jours
en été c'est incroyable c'était c'est un
grand moment pour nous
les racines aériennes de ce maïs sont de
formidables capteurs d'azoté elle
sécrète d'abord un gel qu'elles
remplissent de sucre afin d'attirer des
bactéries fixatrices d'azoté
une fois ces bactéries bien implanté
elle se met à capter la zot directement
de l'air un peu comme le font les
légumineuses elle convertissent ensuite
cet azote en ammonium une molécule
facilement assimilable par le maïs
l'ammonium deviendra la source d'azoté
et de nourriture dont le maïs a besoin
pour sa croissance
la découverte du chercheur est
considérable
fabriquer de l'engrais de synthèse et
très polluant il faut une tonne de gaz
naturel pour produire une tonne
d'engrais azotés cette industrie
accapare à elle seule 1 % de toute
l'énergie produite sur terre et c'est
sans compter que les surplus d'engrais
polluent les cours d'eau mais pour que
le maïs mexicain gagne les champs
beaucoup de travail reste à faire
voici le terrain d'étude du chercheur en
automne le maïs conventionnelles et
prêts à être récoltés et la variété g1
du oaxaca a besoin de six mois de plus
pour produire ces épis ce genre nous
deux mais ce qu'on peut pas utiliser non
au système agronomique conventionnel on
a besoin de maïs qui sont plus petits et
on a besoin de maïs qu'il pousse plus
rapidement
le chercheur veut amener le maillage
commercial à produire ses propres
racines aériennes
claudia calderon fait partie de l'équipe
mise sur pied pour créer une nouvelle
lignée de mai est comme d'autres
généticien du maïs elle ignorait les
fonctions de ce gel
[Musique]
je sais qu'au mexique
les enfants mangent de ce gel parce que
c'est sucré mais personne ne connaissait
jusqu'ici sa réelle utilité
c'est un grand pas en avant
son travail consiste à introduire par
croisements naturels les jeunes
responsables des racines aériennes dans
les lignes commerciales mais créer de
nouvelles variétés et risques et les
croisements pourrait réduire la capacité
du nouveau mail à capter la zot
les chercheurs ont bon espoir d'y
parvenir nous savons que ses racines
aériennes sont un trait qu'il
transmissibles ce qui est un bon point
de départ
le reste c'est une question
d'observation sur le terrain afin de
faire les bonnes sélections
je suis confiante et je pense qu'on aura
des lignes est intéressante à partager
avec les agriculteurs
d'une manière générale un consensus que
s'ils n'arrivent à voir un maïs qui fixe
10% à peu près de son âge haute 10 15%
en azote dans ce cas là on a vraiment un
maïs qui pourraient être utiles points
pour un grand nombre de deux des
producteurs
le chercheur c'est que le travail qui
reste à accomplir sera parsemé
d'embûches mêle aventure en vaut le coup
un maïs qui puise une partie de son gaz
hotte dans l'air améliorerait le lourd
bilan environnemental de cette culture
mais il pourrait aussi aider les
producteurs des pays en développement à
bien des endroits mais paysans n'ont
tout simplement pas accès à de beaux sol
ni aucun fertilisants pour cultiver du
maïs ce genre de chose sûre que je pense
que je suis sur mon vieux quand je vais
au travail si on pouvait avoir un impact
avec ce maïs dans 10 ans 20 ans c'est
clair ce serait une norme et c'est une
grosse motivation pour nous
[Musique]
la découverte de maïs géant qui pousse
sur des sols pauvres montre bien que la
nature trouve parfois des solutions que
les chercheurs n'auraient jamais pu
imaginer le fait d'avoir trouvé ce maïs
qui est qui obtient des taux d'azoté
très significatif de l'air est vraiment
vraiment incroyable
mais pour jean-michel année cette
découverte me rappelle avant tout
l'importance de conserver la
biodiversité végétale au début de ma
carrière
il ya même 20 ans je n'aurais jamais
pensé atteindre arriver à trouver ça
j'espérais pas pas ce niveau-là compte
c'était
[Musique]